>> Hello YouTube. I am a Rabbi, part of the
religous group here at the world economic
forum and we have come here and I have a short
rebuttal. It's like two people in a boat in
the midst of the ocean. One of the men is
drilling a hole in the boat and the other
one says you are killing yourself, killing
me too, why are you doing it? And the answer
of the man is, well, I'm only drilling a hole
in my part of the boat. We are all in the
boat so we have come to repentance because
the anchors and all of us have made great
mistakes. As a Rabbi, I also want to say that
I feel the pain of every Palestinian child
who was wounded, killed in Gaza. I feel the
pain of every Isreali child. But I think sharing
our pain is the one way in which we can really
build peace. And that was why the religous
leaders have meet here in Davos. We have made
the appeal. Let's try to look at each other's
eyes. We need each other and you know, I was
a child in 1943, a baby, and I was saved by
a catholic woman, a German woman and she opened
her door for me. Let's open the doors to all
the babies of the world. Therefore, if I have
one request to all the business people, the
politicians, the religous people, to you,
let's together make sure that the Millenium
Development Bills will be realized. Which
means, that in 2015, every child of the world
will have basic education, and every child
will have fresh water. When we do that then
we are trustworthy and repentant and there
will be peace.